[Music]
now in this week's magazine we review
the latest book by janine giovanni she's
been a work correspondent now an
academic at yale university she's
written about the plight of christianity
in the middle east she joins me now um
janine you've got um
so many stories inside you why did you
want to write this one about the fate of
religion
well basically i've been working in the
middle east for three decades and around
the time of saddam hussein
in the early 2000s i became aware of the
christian communities in iraq now these
are people who are basically living in
the land of the prophets uh the land of
jonah of saint thomas and how they were
in danger of being eradicated entirely
since the rise of the islamic state in
2014 in places like iraq and syria these
communities who are very ancient very
rooted to their land are even more
vulnerable
so what i decided was really to focus on
four very distinct communities in the
middle east in iraq in syria in egypt
and in the gaza strip
and why they are so desperately
important that these people remain in
their ancestral lands now of course
christianity was a middle eastern
exports and so therefore it's been in
the middle east for way longer than it
has been in europe um so why should it
be that after going through two
millennia of tumult in these countries
it's under its most in danger now as you
say in your book
absolutely well first of all it's very
interesting because most british
christians and american christians don't
really associate i mean they know that
jesus christ was born in bethlehem but
they don't really associate the birth of
christianity being in in the holy land
and that these ancient communities the
assyrians the called and caldians the
cops are such a unique part of biblical
and indeed history so really what recent
events um have led to their
they could be even extinction within 100
years first of all is the rise of
radical groups so let's take the islamic
state
one of their edicts was to basically
wipe out christians in that part of iraq
which was of course mosul um and and the
northern villages leading into kurdistan
the second thing and i've just stressed
that each community has their own
individual challenges um so for instance
in iraq
it's geopolitics but it really also is
climate change um
iraq is one of the most vulnerable
countries in the middle east in terms of
climate change but it's also about
migration mass of vast migration that
these young people there's no industry
there's no incentive for them to stay
so every community has a very different
story to tell the cops in egypt for
instance are extremely discriminated
against it's enshrined within the
egyptian constitution that they cannot
hold offices of high position in the
government or in the um the army which
of course is an arm of the government um
in the gaza strip it's an entirely
different thing there's only 800
christians left there and of course
christianity gaza had been entirely
christian until the 4th century so these
800 remaining people
are basically sandwiched in between
hamas
and the israeli
occupation even though the israelis
withdrew they are still very much
subjugating the people there the 11-day
bombing in may left gaza devastated
again again so each community has has
unique challenges that
are allowing them to remain and indeed
to populate because their numbers are
dwindling drastically but to what extent
were the dictators actually a friend of
the christians because let's take saddam
hussein for example his deputy from
memory tariq aziz was a christian um in
syria and the christians had an okay
time under assad it was when assad was
on the ropes but they started to get
worried and even in egypt the cops were
pretty much i mean correct me if i'm
wrong here but free to worship in peace
until its recent regime changes and only
then do you end up with them christians
in egypt being attacked outside their
churches so i wonder to what to extend
the the regime changes over the last two
decades have ushered in the forces which
washed out the christians
absolutely this was one of the stranger
things that i came across so you're
absolutely right the christians were
protected in iraq under saddam hussein
there was a sort of unofficial deal with
the devil that further voting block
in exchange they would basically be left
alone
the same thing in syria and this is
something that really shocked me
especially as i reported the war in
syria um
when i would go to the christian
communities there they would you know
basically state their absolute love for
bashar al-assad now whether or not this
is a fear that they had to say this or
whether or not it's basically that they
felt we'd rather have assad than have
the devil that might come afterwards in
other words we do not want the black
flag
same with the christians under mubarak
in egypt um and then the ensuing chaos
that led after the egyptian revolution
the muslim brotherhood and as for the
gazans um
they were probably the most closed
community it was the most difficult for
me to penetrate that community even
though i've been working in gaza since
1990 um
and i think basically they
most of the people said that hamas did
not bother them they were more what was
more disturbing for them was their
inability to leave gaza to join their
brethren in bethlehem for christmas or
easter and the israeli authorities
prevented them from doing that but
absolutely the link between christians
and dictators is very strong and very
very strange
all right and do you think that
christians um
you know who would leave any of these
countries could come to britain and
claim under the human definition a
reasonable fear of persecution because
from what you'd say in your book
it's a pretty brave guy who keeps going
to church right now in some of these
areas where you become a target if you
do so and now they are you also document
in your book how they're leaving in
quite num huge numbers ought they be
going to britain and america or not
they'll be received because
and perhaps because of part
interventions there a couple of decades
ago but there are no doubts under
persecution now
absolutely and i mean so in 2017 2016
2017 when president trump issued his
muslim ban on refugees coming to the u.s
who were muslim
that did not include christians arab
christians now remember they're arabs
but they're christians and for me at
that time i was working for the u.n
refugee agency it sent up a terrible
message which is that we have good
refugees and we have bad refugees i.e
good refugees being christian so
christian communities in britain
in france which is catholic country in
spain in italy
and in the u.s generally welcome canada
as well is another big point where where
a lot of the christians go generally
welcome these refugees whereas muslim
refugees especially now in the wake of
the fall of the taliban
are
flooding europe and elsewhere and this
has different considerations and
concerns
um
another thing is that the the taliban
falling
sends a terrible message
for these christian communities in the
middle east because it basically means
that
other radical groups and let's face it
the islamic state might have been
defeated but they are not gone they're
regrouping they're rebranding the
recruiting under different methods and
there are numerous other groups that
have been vastly empowered by the fall
of the taliban
so this leaves the christian communities
in iraq in syria in these other places
even more vulnerable which is why we
really have to draw attention to their
play
and jeanine you met lots of these
christians these people who risked their
lives to show up to church did you get a
sense of why they were doing it why not
simply worship
in private why would you um risk
everything that you've got simply to
show up at your normal place of worship
if you're a clergyman why would you keep
doing that when you knew the you'd be a
massive target for somebody and you'd be
safer is seeking exile in a faraway land
the answer that i got over and over was
one word love
all of them told me for instance when
the islamic state rolled through mosul
the christians that got out some of them
got out at the very last minute
literally with the clothes on their
backs and their documents but others
stayed in mosul and
the is the isis basically gave them a
choice you can convert or we kill you or
you pay a huge fee and they took their
farmland and they put the letter n for
nazarene over their door marking them as
followers of jesus now i totally agree
with you if i was tossed into the lion's
den as a as a christian in the roman
times i'm not sure i could have
withstand withstood the torture
but these people feel that their faith
is what identifies them it's who they
are and we're talking about 2 000 years
of faith
and of history so what they would say to
me
why do they remain why don't they go to
the to britain why don't they why don't
they convert to islam
because of their love their profound and
deep love of their faith they're linked
to the land and their link to their to
their religion which is of the most
utmost important to their identity
[Music]
you